this isn't what I noticed very strongly  as if I needed any evidence when I was  knocking on doors in my well and have  full constituency on Saturday morning  the people were saying look I'm about to  take on another shift at work because  I'm so worried about mortgage rates and  I understand that rates are going up  because inflation was high because of  Putin's Invasion but what they didn't  understand is why the government would  be borrowing money in order to fund a a  tax reduction for people who are better  off and in doing so spooking the markets  and potentially making those mortgage  rates even higher in the process so the  policy didn't stack up and it didn't  make sense and it's absolutely right and  proper and I'm very pleased it's been  done quickly that the government's  u-turned on this and I strongly welcome  it this morning